ah yes his acting career with football
goes from Polk high to Little Giants now
he's on Modern Family Season 9 begins
tomorrow night on ABC on Modern Family
one of the funniest shows of all time
which it is great to see back here on
the Rich Eisen show Ed O'Neill good to
see you sir thanks rich nice to be so
again it's funny every time you come in
here I hear a news story from you off
air that I'm like yeah you got it let's
talk about this on the air and it all
comes from your the fact that you're
from Youngstown yeah because it's like
every football coach or a bunch of
football players or Eddie DeBartolo
they're you know what you grew up with
all these example right
the Stoops brothers and NAR doozy you
know his son now is playing I I know his
father coached me in high school whose
father Dolan are dudes okay other the
kid at Pitt yeah the head coach I call
him kid he's the head coach of Pitt yeah
his father coached me in high school and
Jerry Hanlon coach me in high school who
was a 30-year assistant coach at
Michigan with the Bo Bo Schembechler
rules you know from Maya he the cradle
of coaches and as it's known in Miami
off Ohio because yes it's right with
with a teammate of mine named Jimmy Shaw
mm-hmm yeah did you did you know Bo well
well I covered Bo's final season for the
Michigan daily okay in 1990 and that was
a lifetime memory well I'll never forget
where I was the first person in the room
at his weekly press availability at it
would be at a local restaurant yeah and
I was sitting there eating a hamburger
by myself at the table and Bo would had
her heart surgery twice over couldn't
eat it and he just sits down just being
Bo Schembechler he's not eating I'm
eating and I'm like oh my god do I keep
eating do I get up what do I do
and he just looks at me and he goes
how's that taste
did you see I'm not him through Jerry
Hanlon okay and because when I was out
here I was doing
married with children they played in the
Rose Bowl with Brady pretty senior year
97 yes okay I came out and Jerry called
me and said we
you know we're practicing in Pasadena
why don't you come out and meet the team
well Brian Griese was the quarterback at
that team Brady was probably like third
string or fourth string or something
like that at the time so you met Tom I
met I met him then yeah and then later I
did a pilot with him with jennifer Love
Hewitt
he had won his first Super Bowl I think
or May it might even been a second hold
on a second what do you mean you did a
pilot with Tom Brady yeah I'll call it
with Tom Brady and Jennifer Love
Jennifer Love Hewitt and the who was the
great linebacker at Penn State and
unfortunately got got injured and didn't
play a whole lot that same age is Brady
huh oh he was a all-american parent yes
he was in the pilot and another player
to him what was her father you know and
uh-huh and this was this was funny
because she came to me she was single
and so was he but I think she didn't
know he was sort of engaged so she said
would you go to him and tell him that
I'm interested in him I think he's love
hewitt wanted to use you I don't kneel
as Cupid with Tommy she wanted me to be
the cupid yeah I think I did it I
mentioned Brady Brady but Brady's wound
up on top I think he's done all right
he's got he's done he's done all right
for himself he's done all right
so you met Brady back in the day through
so and when you met bo2 at the time met
Bo the same time
yeah bo is here bo is here that's the
lot the last time I saw Bo was before
the Rose Bowl game at Michigan lost a
Vince Young in Texas yeah in the mid
arts and he passed away the next year
yeah he died the next year yeah Bo man
I'll tell you what a lot of Michigan
people come through the pipeline say my
brother's life graduated from Michigan
out a hole Michigan thing well the guys
from Youngstown played for Michigan
right and so what was it like you said
you grew up around the Stoops family -
yeah the Stoops Bobby Stoops and his
brothers and then his father his father
was L of a coach right and so I I just
had dinner
Bobby like maybe oh I guess it's two
years ago yeah out here this whole
family Bobby and I and I I tell you guys
don't know cuz you look at him you don't
I don't know he said he was a defensive
back who would really light you up
[Laughter]
fastest guy in the world
uh-huh but if he hit you you stayed hit
what was what was your game like my game
yeah what was your game like Ed O'Neill
was your football game I mean I was it I
was I was probably a hitter I was a
hitter you weren't you didn't wrap up
you didn't take someone down sometimes I
made the mistake of not wrapping up he'd
go back five yards and then turn around
and go you know keep going well you're
on the D line right you're in the D line
yeah I played like a middle guard
linebacker defensive end I played tight
end a little bit you know I was like
trying to find you know what could I
play in the pros I was only 225 but then
I needed to be but the Steelers knocked
on your door I know we've discussed this
before but you know and in light of the
fact of Dan Rooney passing away last
yeah did you have any interaction with
the Rooneys at all when you are you at
right yeah I met Dan and I met well I
mean art art hard I met all right the
big art I mean I'll tell you but listen
I'll tell you a funny story it's brief
okay I was at Sofia Vergara's wedding in
Florida by the way great way to start a
story yeah with Joe Carroll Joe
Manganiello yes big Steeler fan Big West
huge color fans so I had a good in there
cuz I had you know had a cup of coffee
with them so I'm standing at the
reception having a drink and a guy got
proaches me and says there's a guy here
I'm with who is your biggest fan and
he's over there but he's too shy to
approach and I looked over and I said
that's Franco Harris
he said yes it's Franco Harris now
Franco Harris came the year after I was
cut okay cuz I would have been with like
Terry Bradshaw well no no um I was
rookie with Luke Gilliam
no well Gilliam was on the team no good
but no Terry Hanratty okay from Notre
Dame mm-hmm
so Franco comes over and I you know we
shake hands and I'm looking at him you
know
Oh mr. O'Neil you know I mean he was
like I don't know he was shy and I said
Franco wait a minute you're my biggest
fan he says absolutely
I shouldn't everything you've done I
said hang on I was there the year before
you I lasted about two weeks or so I
don't know would I get cut you come in
win four Super Bowls I'm your idol I
didn't even make the team no oh we had a
great time so he looks like he'd still
play by the way yes he does
yeah yes he did guy I know and him and
and what he stands for with the Steelers
organization and for all those years so
Manganiello I mean talk about well now
I'm just putting two together because I
didn't know he got to invite Franco
Harris to his wedding I mean a lot of
guys there was a lot of people there I
mean it was like a list a list there was
one of the owners that I had drinks with
afterwards okay and probably they're not
all Rooney's now no no Thomas Tull I'm
sure that - it was okay no everything
but I think I do
oh great so are there any other players
that were there - no but there was the
guys from the strip movie you know all
those guys from Magic Mike little
[Laughter]
anymore I do yeah anymore and in fact
the guy the owner said you know we you
got to come down here and we got it you
know see a game and you know we'll put
you in a box and let's take a break here
I want to talk about how you tapped out
on Mayweather McGregor won't even touch
gloves okay because I know you're a big
MMA guy an O'Neill of modern family love
chat with him back in 60 seconds and
again if you're on hold we'll take your
phone calls before we close up shop here
on this busy Tuesday
you
[Music]
we are back in so it's Modern Family
Season 9 premieres tomorrow night at
9:00 eastern time on ABC Eric
Stonestreet who's been on the show
before big Chiefs fan he's got to be
fired up that they're three and oh he
loves Kansas State ty Burrell's Rams are
two and one my gosh Ed O'Neill here for
another segment here on the Rich Eisen
show we'll talk about modern family in a
second you are an MMA guy right you love
all I want a smart mixed martial oh yeah
you do jujitsu yourself on it with the
Gracie's fro as a hobby no huh for a
long long time 30 years maybe okay for
30 years 30 years yeah what do you like
about it I'm not sure it's it's a kind
of a fascinating martial art okay so you
just enjoy they did I just enjoy the
technique of it to get you calm does it
calm you down
yeah when it's over when it's all if you
go to sleep especially right and I know
so it soaked out so what did you what
what did you think of Mayweather
McGregor well when I heard they were
gonna do it I first of all I didn't
think it would ever happen you know I
thought that makes no sense
well I mean the money you knew that that
somebody would wanna gonna I've started
to think if they're gonna give the you
know McGregor a hundred million dollars
I would do it I would have how many
rounds you think it could have gone well
I would have made it as short as
possible I think I would have been
looking for a soft spot you know this
sucks
yeah but so then I thought well he's not
gonna you know can't it's apples and
oranges you know there's two different
disciplines right so I knew that he had
no real chance no chance would she 100
101 or less or more oh puncher's chance
though right yeah but see so you didn't
even buy the fight no I had no interest
in watching did you have did you go
online or no see what happened no and
one of the few times I've never done
that
do you know what happened in the fight I
heard I heard I mean I don't think
anything about that huh you know I mean
if it had been an MMA rules it would
have been a half around where we're
going with what hits the floor with the
kicks
it kicked the legs out from under right
it would have been it would have been
boring to the point that Mayweather
probably would have taken two kicks and
backed up and looked at the ref and
knelt down you know to $500 for your
seat and that would have been it right
and what so did you triple G and Alvarez
you check that one out that one I
actually didn't see it I saw the
highlights okay
and of course you know that was bad
referring that was that was crazy you've
got to be kidding me up right yeah I
mean 118 110 is a blowout and he's the
champ and then the other cards are much
tighter one call it a draw which even a
draws horrible exactly about if if okay
if say somebody had given Alvarez the
fight by two points on another card we'd
be still talking about that yes but even
if that it happened we'd be talking more
about the draw card than anything else
right now
well it's boxing boxing is just stinks
yeah but you so you would one was less
aren't even any good fighters what's the
last fight you bought then Edie jeez I
don't I don't remember I don't buy them
anymore huh I don't buy him I just I
don't I mean I'm you know I I'm like I
was a huge boxing fan all my life
mm-hm and I saw deteriorating over the
years you know with West fighters and
less trainers and you know you fight
once a year now and it's usually hand
pick you saw Jake LaMotta passed away
recently Sarge I knew Jake because you
know he when I was doing knockout on
Broadway with Aiello he he came it was
right after Raging Bull came out and
interesting fella yeah tough guy I mean
you know one of the one of the great
tough it's just getting to meet him like
that yeah okay I met Dempsey you met
Dempsey today I got my picture taken
with Dempsey I came to the play you've
just you've crossed and you know we
showed on the television only segment
last hour
the dinner would dawn the Don Rickles
series is coming out online that the arp
arp put together or that i was fortunate
to sit down and do with him you met
Rickles - yeah I knew Don Don was a
great guy very funny very kind guy how
did you get to meet Don Rickles years
ago I did that show he was on that I did
a what was it the tic-tac-toe thing the
Hollywood Squares that's where I met him
on Hollywood Squares so you were a
square on how is the story I don't know
why ever did that show but I did do it
he was doing it a number of other people
were doing it and then so you know you'd
do a lot of them in one day one or two
days you do quite a few sure so I got to
know him and then later I'd run into him
well you know Mastro's take whatever you
know right see somebody I was with
somebody and they said hey Don you know
this guy over here what is this a test
he couldn't see me
you know oh I thought it could be maybe
that was just uh well then he came on
first line my wife told me was you know
this a great guy I know gone he had a
life in full to save Modern Family
Season nine back again the whole crew
back again got me a little nervous that
it might not happen at but we're we're
here though right well you know that's
negotiations that's the way it works
yeah okay is it you got to say hey I
don't mind Hawaii that's the that's the
yeah that's the tactic see ya
Aloha right yeah but you're in still
enjoying doing it oh I love doing it I
love doing okay job ever had more than
more than married with children yeah
because it's less work you know it's
three families and when you're not when
the other two families are working
you're not mm-hmm right that's about two
and a half days a week or three days a
week right and is this the last season
no we're contracted for another one okay
so we're gonna go ten and then that then
now it's open-ended but I don't know
about after ten you know but there's
this one of them there's the next one
that's right yeah that's right well it's
as funny as ever at man it is I think it
is I mean I can't wait to see
these episodes and and you know we're
gonna get I think stone streets coming
in in a couple of weeks it's great he is
and it's funny cuz Tai pretends he's the
same kind of sports fan but he's not ok
what do you mean by you know he'll tease
little tease Eric about it you know and
then say but he's the Oregon Ducks yeah
and he made up a little song you know
and he sings it to him with you they're
fast they're fast oh they're so fast you
can't catch them you know it's like fast
they are yeah there goes nuts yeah and
you did a scene you did a scene with
Peyton Manning last year right well I
did a show we did a whole show that I'll
show he can't play coach Bob or
something how was he great he was really
great you know it's funny though because
I had done a documentary I did the
voiceover of his document of the time on
yeah timeline right so I knew about his
preparation you know in football it was
its legendary his preparation mm-hmm I
was amazed and he did the same thing for
the show he wanted to know this and you
know when I said Peyton just just do it
don't worry about he asked you like fer
he was asking our producers like what
kind of character I'm not playing myself
I'm playing a character and no man it's
his first 15 script oh sure and then
he's it but he's mr. audible - so you
didn't he was he did fine
huh great he's as good as they come and
you know he's six five hmm he's a big
guy yeah that's why he's on the Mount
Rushmore yeah thanks for coming on my
pleasure I love it when you come in here
and thanks thanks for thanks for being
here and again thanks for not going to
Hawaii yet and doing Modern Family for
Season nine and ten well I was hoping
they'd come around I'm glad it all
worked out it all premieres 9:00 Eastern
on ABC tomorrow the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches